e
well thank you very much I don't often
get here so but uh this
being a pressing need uh my name is
James Gray I represent Senate District 6
which starts up in Alton gilmon comes
down Route 11 to
Rochester um State Prison uh uh needs to
be
replaced if you look back at our history
of state prisons and uh uh the Court
decisions that have told us that uh that
we have to take action um and you've
seen the pictures I'm sure that they've
been distributed to you um this is
something that has to happen uh right
now there is room in the state budget uh
that this $40 million uh can be bought
fed uh that the treasurer has confirmed
that to me uh in emails and it is
something that is due it's something
that is needed uh and if we are really
you know interested in the recidivism
rate uh we need to make the
facilities
uh such that uh that we can uh help that
along so I'll be willing to ask answer
any questions but but uh I'm sure that
the Department of Corrections is here to
testify and they probably can answer
much better than I thank you Senator
questions for the
senator yes please represent
foli this is just for the design right
this is just for the design and
preliminary work
yes thank you further questions for the
are very expensive uh
represent Mills yes sir yes sir Senator
do we have any idea what the total cost
of building is going to be what we're
looking forward to after this initial
I've heard some estimates but I would
rather get get that information right
from the Department of Corrections thank
you sir further questions Senator
Greg seeing none thank you for your time
sir I'll go back to election law then
thank you
now um I would like to um call John
Graham former chairman Public Works and
highways thank you Mr chairman for the
record I am John Graham I live in
Bedford and for 20 sub years I was on
this committee so I understand um how
this works I would like to remind
everybody what I said when House Bill 25
was being heard a little over a year ago
that
the governor had proposed this $40
million for this engineering design and
look in house uh House Bill too the
legislature I.E the finance committee
saw fit to take that $40 million out so
that brings us back here trying to
borrow the $40 million to do that and
we've lost a year on this I'd also like
to ask how many of you around this table
have been in the The Men's prison
to take a
tour I am sure that the rest of you if
you ask the commissioner while he's here
talking that he can arrange a tour so
you can see what the problem is we've
been kicking this can for at least two
decades and for those who've been on
this committee for a while you realize
that the only reason we have a new
women's prison is that we lost a court
case and we had to build it to the
specific ations of the court and not to
any kind of study or design so you have
a hard decision to make on whether or
not to do this 40 million bonding
outside of the capital
budget understanding that in probably
27 um H House Bill 25 you're going to
have to deal with actually taking the
study and deciding what to do with
um the study and where you're going to
build it how large and all the rest I'm
sure that there will be people who go we
don't need to build a new prison or or
whatever
but my personal opinion is having looked
at this and put uh Band-Aids on the
whole problem for two decades that we
need to start doing something um how
we're going to fund it I will leave to
the general court which I'm no longer
part of thank
God for some of this
but um that's all I wanted to say Mr
chairman I think I went over by two
minutes I said that I'd do but it's good
always good to be here thank you um
thank you representative and um
Chairman's privileged to run long so uh
qu questions uh for former
chairman yes please repres thank you
chairman
good morning could you briefly describe
the
conditions and and briefly what we've
been through the past 20 years we've
we've fixed roofs we've tried to fix
some of the plumbing uh we fixed the
Locking mechanisms on doors so that that
the doors would lock um right now um
couple of iterations ago we did work on
the sewer system because things get
flushed down the the the system that
probably shouldn't be going doubt it um
but you'll see some pictures hopefully
from the Department on rain and other
water coming down into the kitchen area
uh there are deteriorating there's mold
there's a spe we can go on and on but
I'd like to leave that to the department
because I'm sure that they have um
pictures because they always bring
pictures of of the problem um um and
this is a start on the solution as as
far as I can see um it will determine
where how large what's it's going to
cost and I know that uh representative
fidal asked it 4 million for um just
design and Engineering that's about
typical of a 10% cost for a major
project you put that much into it so
that's what we're looking at whether
it's 300
400 or less or more who knows until it's
done represent Melvin thank
you could you tell me when the uh prism
was built no I I'll leave all those
kinds of questions to the department it
was in the 1800s part of it 1800s yes
and um any further
questions
um and actually the 1800s part is the
better better facility than what we've
added on yeah all right thank you thank
you for your testimony you're always
welcome back here you really mean that
Mr chairman well it has been a few
months we were starting to miss you so
thank you thank you Mr chairman the uh
for the some of the newer board members
the suggestion is actually what we need
to do uh once you've been there you will
never forget it and um the uh one of the
terms when we were talking about through
the C capital budget and the
conversation came up to how bad a roof
was was how many buckets were containing
the water that came that came from this
facility so with
that I would like to
recognize
um well who is here for here we go uh Mr
Raymond Paul
Raymond New Hampshire Department of
Corrections good
morning uh the New Hampshire Department
of Corrections enthusiastically supports
Senate Bill uh 476 so Mr chairman
honorable members of the com uh capital
budget committee thank you for allowing
me the opportunity to speak with you
this morning in support of this
legislation my name is Paul Raymond Jr
I'm the assistant commissioner for the
New Hampshire Department of
Corrections uh being handed around today
is a copy of my testimony as well as uh
some slides that have been printed off
to give you a small glimpse into what
we're dealing with at the New Hampshire
state prison for men
currently uh the department extends our
thanks to Senator gray and all the
co-sponsors on this crucial piece of
legislation it goes without saying but
the New Hampshire state prison for men
is an aged inefficient facility with
very poor conditions for both our staff
and those who work there it's also
important to recognize that our staff
are gen Al working 16 hour shifts a day
due to our our significantly High
vacancy rate right now uh staff members
generally come in for an 8 hour shift
and are often forced into a 16h hour
shift due to our minimum standards to
make sure that we can maintain Safety
and Security at the
facilities as was mentioned earlier the
current prison campus style Correctional
Facility was originally built in
1878 we are in fact still using parts of
that original structure
for housing uh and programming and the
last time that the structure received
significant Renovations was in the 1980s
when we added uh several additional
structures for far too long the
operational and structural needs of the
New Hampshire state prison for men have
been unmet and the demands of running a
large 247 Correctional Facility focused
on Rehabilitation are catching up with
the architectural failures like much of
the country
Corrections in general is on the brink
of failure this $40 million
appropriation is needed to identify the
next steps in the replacement of the New
Hampshire state prison for men I won't
read my entire testimony for you but I
do want to highlight some of the key
points that that I've identified for you
first is our Recruitment and Retention
concerns so while the conditions are
poor and and challenging in general for
our residents who live there it's
simultaneously just as difficult for the
people who have to work there and like I
mentioned earlier with our with our
Correctional uh entry-level Corrections
Officers vacancy rate hovering around
50% it's not uncommon for us to force
our staff into working 16 hour shifts so
16 hours nearly five days a week in
harsh conditions is really difficult to
retain people people generally come to
work for us but unfortunately due to the
condition they're often looking for
other opportunities of employment we're
not going to hire our way out of the
vacancy rate we have to retain the good
people that we have working hard in our
facilities every single day making
changes to our Correctional environment
is going to help us retain
staff it's important to recognize that
the the structural issues and the lack
of ventilation throughout the facility
make it nearly unbearable during the
summer months for our staff especially
in fact we close down housing units
because of how unbearable it gets due to
the Heat and the poor air
ventilation the other thing to keep in
mind is that the depart US Department of
Labor has already identified that uh in
the next 10 years they expect a greater
than 7% decrease in the workforce for
Corrections Officers we're already at a
significant significant vacancy rate and
we know through projections that that's
probably going to get
worse when we talk about Rehabilitation
that's one of our primary
responsibilities at the Department of
Corrections we know statistically that
greater than 95% of people incarcerated
today are going to be
released it's our responsibility to
rehabilitate them or at least give them
the opportunity to
rehabilitate it's very difficult to do
that in a facility that was built with
punishment in mind not
Rehabilitation right this is an old
facility built in the 1800s designed
around the Pennsylvania style of
penitentiary right sit by yourself and
be remorseful we know that that doesn't
work we know that we need to provide
effective programming to all of these
residents in order for them to become
better members of society it's our
responsibility to provide uh education
vocational training mental health
treatment and substance misuse
programming so that when the residents
are ready to be released they have
successfully met our Rehabilitation
rehabilitative needs a construction uh
sorry a prison constructed in 1878 and
even with the designs and the
enhancements made in
1980 are not uh meeting the advancements
and best practices necessary for
Effective rehabilitation
economically if we just look at the
prison we're looking at spending
approximately $150 million in
band-aiding the prison over the next
five years in the testimony that I've
provided I've outlined exactly what
those are going to look like we're
looking at repairs to significant
concrete needs throughout the building
replacement of electrical Transformers
replacement of the perimeter fence as
well as roads and parking lots and that
doesn't even get into the roofs
and the actual structure of the
buildings that are going to need to be
worked on we also recognize that five
years beyond that we're estimating to
spend another $250
million so these repairs over the next
10 years are well over half of the cost
of a new facility which at this time
with the Department of administrative
Services cost estimates we received just
this past week we estimate the cost of a
new prison facility is going to be
approximately $584
million given the current rate of
inflation this cost is expected to
increase exponentially over the next
several years the time is now to take
action and to start making an
improvement to our prison
facility the department appreciates the
$10 million that we received in the
budget and that allows us for a a full
sight evaluation of the proect
prospective site which is going to be
located behind
the current New Hampshire correctional
facility for women in
conquered however for the Department to
move forward with the architectural and
engineering and forecasting for the
replacement facility it would cost
approximately 10% as was previously
mentioned so we need this additional $40
million to get toward that architectural
and engineering design
phase uh you've likely heard about the
issues we're having in the kitchen uh we
continue to significant issues in the
kitchen at the Men's prison and in fact
there are pictures in the attachments
for you where you can see it does
require us to have a lot of tarps as
well as hosing to make sure that the
water doesn't drip onto the food
preparation areas we've worked hand
inand with our partners at the
Department of Health and Human Services
Division of Public Health services to
ensure that we have a safe and clean
environment but at the end of the day we
really need to replace the prison the
prison
kitchen replacement of the kitchen today
in the current environment would cost
over $1 million and it doesn't sound
fiscally responsible to spend $ million
when in turn we really need a new prison
in
general we also have the reception and
diagnostic unit that I want to call
attention to you've got pictures of what
we commonly call R&D and this is
generally where people who are newly
incarcerated will come into the prison
facility the facility is is uh that's
part of the original 1878 facility that
we have at the prison that we're still
using we continue to have water leaks
and in fact we've brought in numerous um
plumbers and and Engineers to assist us
and given the old infrastructure and
architecture of that building none of
them are willing to actually do the
necessary work to completely fix it all
we're doing is literally putting
Band-Aids on the
problem and then when we talk about
technology we're driving to try to make
uh our our department more efficient for
our employees we're trying to find ways
that we can Implement technology that's
going to drive efficiencies and make it
easier for people to work with us uh
we're not able to do that in the age of
uh infrastructure that we currently have
as well as the large campus footprint so
we're trying to do uh Implement
technologies that will allow us to make
it easier for people to do their jobs
but also we're trying to only Implement
technology IES that we know today that
we could pick up and move to a
replacement
facility so in closing I just want to
emphasize that the dangers are real the
Department of Corrections is asking this
committee to further back us in our
mission to provide secure Humane
supervision and evidence-based
Rehabilitation and to support the
replacement of the New Hampshire state
prison for men my testimony today is
only a brief snapshot of the many
reasons why a replacement Correctional
Facility is needed
once again on behalf of the Department
of Corrections I thank the sponsors of s
SP 476 for helping us to take this large
step forward for our goal of replacing
the facility thank you again for this
opportunity and I'm happy to take any
questions that you may have you have
many thank you commissioner uh repr Jack
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
commissioner um if I understood what you
said correctly there's agreement on a on
a site for the new prison that is is
determined to be
suitable yes we we have uh we have
plenty of property behind the existing
prisons the the men's Correctional
Facility and the women's correctional
facility that is more than sufficient
for the footprint of a new Correctional
Facility represent V
please Mr chair I probably got a couple
but
um I got Quant fully support your
concept um but a lot of concerns
like if you do this are you looking
design a facility that can operate with
peer employees we are saving money by
having double
overtime um and I don't think you're
going to be able to get the budget to
accommodate what you actually need for
straight 8 hour shfs we can't afford it
are we
building in an Optimum
location or are we
building because we have
the property that is not
Optimum and are we planning longterm
because the structural failures that I'm
seeing here my first visit to the state
prison was 1975 when there was an open
sewer going through the
cafeteria uh and I've been through
multiple uh changes since the largest
vote I took was to expand the prison in
1980 that we were promised would carry
us through 19 uh
2050 and then we had to build burlin so
it's failed
so what how comfortable you folks in
your long-term planning are we building
like we did with the women's prison a
postage stamp because we had the
property or are we building where we can
maximize what the property is or should
we be looking
elsewhere I appreciate that question I I
think we are building in the ideal
location for a number of reasons first
we have the the majority of our staff
are currently working conquered to to
move out of uh the current environment I
think would be a challenge to some of
our staff members um I I would say that
we are forecasting for what is necessary
but in this 40 million it will allow us
to do not only a population assessment
but also a staffing assessment so beyond
the engineering and design we need to do
that Staffing assessment to determine
what's necessary for this facility as
you know we can operate because of
efficiencies built in into the northern
New Hampshire correctional facility and
the correctional facility for women we
can operate with fewer staff right we
have a very old facility right now and
and I'll just call attention to the
reception and Diagnostics unit right so
on uh page eight of my testimony there's
a picture of the lever system that's
required to operate the cells uh the
cell doors in that prison so when you
think about a newer environment they're
all remotely controlled from a control
room so a person who's trained
sits there waits for the call from a
corrections officer and opens the door
in this situation we have to add
additional people to not only open the
door but then be at the door and then do
the escort and then with the current R&D
facility it's multi-tiered and there has
to be a person at each door at each
level at each level so when you think
about escorting a person around the
Reception Diagnostics unit takes almost
twice as many people as is necessary to
escort somebody around the Northern New
Hampshire Correctional Facility so we
are factoring that into into our goal in
this replacement facility we have to
factor in the the staffing needs and the
Staffing benefits that I think we're
going to see from this new facility and
then follow up yeah okay yes go ahead
please represent Follow by represent F
all part of your testimony was these
folks have to come out the door um and
that changed with Mr Bennett in 1920 to
change to Corrections instead of
uh punishment um you folks used to have
a great automotive shop and a great body
shop which guaranteed the day they
walked out the door they could have a
job that no longer exists uh is that
because of a lack of Staffing a lack of
instructors or a lack of secure that
seemed to be one of the best things you
had going and it's gone yeah so it
actually it is in operation um it's it's
uh it's in operation in fact I I uh uh
last March I had my are there for an
inspection so they did the inspection
and the work to get my car back on the
road um so we do have the the system uh
in the programming do you still have the
body shop we do have uh the body shop is
not there right yeah um real part of it
is our is Staffing so finding the people
to provide the instruction uh and the
education that goes with that facility
but we also are recognizing the other
opportunities that are available too so
we've expanded our our print shop
um we've added technology there we've
expanded our uh our woodw woodworking
program um so we have uh I I think the
the programming opportunities EVs and
flows with the needs of the not only the
residents but also the needs of uh
assessing the community and so uh
sometimes there isn't uh we can't keep a
program operational but we do still have
the mechanic shop um and and we're
always looking at ways to improve the
ational programming that we bring to the
residents thank you okay thank you
represent representative fidal
please than
you there a couple of things that bother
me you repr I'm we're having a hard time
understanding I
am how many prisoners is the new
facility going to be designed to
house number one
one number
two it seems as
though the real problem at at existing
is that there has not been a very good
maintenance plan in effect for a lot of
years
and whether that's going to happen in
the new prison or not is is critical to
any building you build to have a
maintenance plan so you don't get leaky
roofs you don't get this I
mean it just seems like an enormous
amount of
investment uh is there a question in
there represent fidelie well thank you I
asked one question the other question
is has it ever been considered to
shipping the prisoners out of
state those was my two questions okay um
so the
I'm sorry remind me of the the first
question oh how housing how many how
many residents to house so um we we are
looking at a replacement prison so we we
currently have uh housing for
approximately 1,200 in the New Hampshire
state prison for Med um we uh we are at
a 30-year low when it comes to
population in the prison system in New
Hampshire so um you know some of that
the final number number will be
determined as part of the population
assessment that's done in this phase uh
but there's no commitment that's been
made to a firm number for the the
replacement prison but it is a
replacement prison we're not looking to
um grow or downsize we're looking to
replace the existing prison that we
currently have your other question about
uh sending out of state um we do
participate in the uh interstate compact
uh however the interstate compact does
requ require for everyone that we send
out of state we get one in return so we
do participate in the interstate compact
okay okay thank you represent fidal any
other further questions from the
committee yes go ahead please represent
Boger we have uh built I should say you
have had built two new prisons one I
guess is the Men's prison in the North
country and the other's the women have
we taken the uh
uh the best practices of those prisons
and optimize them so that uh we can have
a better Men's prison here in conquer
that's question one and question two the
location behind the current
prison uh is the site work itself I
understand there might be a lot of
granite back there and would that add to
the cost
ex
over than purchasing land somewhere else
that has less Granite to build
on I appreciate that question so um the
uh yes we are taking in all of the best
practices but I I'll tell you the um the
women's facility is is really the one
that has most of the best practices
current best practices for Correctional
design uh in place um the Northern New
Hampshire Correctional Facility
up in Berlin it does have a lot of best
practices still uh and we will work to
optimize those into any design of a new
Correctional Facility that's for sure um
we see those the the optimization in
both of our newer facilities although
granted the northern Correctional
Facility is almost 25 years old so it's
not as new for a correctional facility
um but it is on the newer side the
women's facility is absolutely new and
and we see uh for lack of a better term
we reap the benefits of that new
facility with our women residents um it
is focused on Rehabilitation it is
focused on
reintegration and uh and we see that
benefit which is why uh our women's
reism rate is better than the rest of
the country so we see that uh just in
the new facility that we have and the
capabilities were able to perform in
that environment um I will say uh for
the for the facility I'm I or for the
footprint uh behind the current women's
prison I'm not an engineer uh but the
engineers that I've spoken with have all
told me that that it is an ideal
facility for uh for what we want to do
back there so I have to I take their
word that uh that it is a a good space
okay thank you further questions of Mr
Raymond yes represent Newman
please yes ju just following up on that
so the Engineers have said it's an ideal
site it's workable but have they said if
there's granite or anything else under
that would require a lot of
extraordinary efforts I I haven't been
uh part of any of those discussions I'm
happy to go back and ask the engineers
uh specifically and we can try and get
an answer to the committee okay thank
you uh okay representative jurors
followed by represent Connor please
thank you
chairman commissioner um I guess the and
continue the thread on the um this the
site work have you have you or the
anybody in the department scoped out a
an alternative property for for for you
know just to compare what it would take
and number two um uh we're still going
to be spending money on maintenance and
uh just from your your presentation here
we're still going to be spending
probably tens of hundreds of thousands
of dollars on until the point we open
the gates to a new facility correct
correct okay thank you okay thank you as
far as uh for your for your first
question I I don't know if we scoped out
any other facilities um but I'm happy to
talk with the engineers and get an
answer back to the committee oh you have
a follow up you have please continue
repr jur and a comment land being at a
premium these days yeah we we own that
property that's currently available
behind us which is one of the reason
reasons you know and then the other part
to be quite candid is um there aren't uh
I I don't think there's a community in
New Hampshire that wants us to build a
new prison in their
Community thank you thank you Mr oh
you're welcome rest of Connor
please thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um now you
said um the women's prison um you said
it's focused on
Rehabilitation how many um I don't know
if you have the numbers but how many
have reoffended after
leaving the prison um our our recidivism
rate is better uh from the women's
prison than the national average I don't
know offhand what the specific number
was or what the number is but I do know
that it is better than the national
average for
recidivism
correct thank welcome further question
representive Edgar
please uh thank you Mr chairman thanks
for answering my question um I'm looking
at uh slide number
four and it it says you have about 1900
is that total prisoners in this state
and could you give a breakdown between
uh what the what the population is for
the major prisons you
have yes uh so we have uh approximately
1900 uh I I think the number this
morning we was 1972 incarcerated in the
state of New Hampshire that includes all
of uh our numbers so we have a uh a one
through five classification system so
one being individuals who are in a
transitional housing unit so the last
step of re-entry into the community uh
we have a couple hundred there and then
uh up to C5 which C5 is our maximum
security uh offenders and uh so
incarcerated in conquered we have
approximately a th000 incarcerated in
the Berlin facility we have
approximately 600 and then there's
approximately 100 at the women's
facility and then the rest are in that
in the transitional housing
units okay can you have a followup uh
yes just a clarification how many um i'
heard you say before that there were
1,200 in the uh the Men's prison is that
correct uh capacity for 1,200 uh there's
approximately a thousand in there right
now thank you you're welcome all right
thank you further questions yes please
representative Melvin thank you you're
welcome thank you for taking my question
do you think that we could use the plans
for the uh the woman's prison for the
new prison instead of spending $40
million for
engineers and just redo that plan a
little bit to accommodate the males
instead of the females so the the
women's facility
is uh right now is about a tenth of the
size of the Men's prison um I I think it
would be challenging to take those plans
which are now almost 10 years old and
try to uh amend them to meet the needs
of a much larger uh prison facility so I
I think it would be challenging to do
that okay okay thank you okay the
questions please yes repres I'm
Carrie uh Paul do you have any idea of
the savings that you might engage in
doing this now as opposed to waiting in
terms of Energy Efficiency or quite
frankly I'm looking at your kitchen and
if I were a restaurant tour in downtown
congr I don't think I would get a a
health pass on that one yeah I um uh I'm
I'm very proud of uh the staff that we
have in the Men's prison because they
have overcome significant challenges in
uh a a a difficult environment to work
in um we did have some struggles with
some of our health inspections uh
however we have passed all of our health
inspections recently because of the hard
work of our staff to overcome those
challenges uh I'm very proud of the work
that they've done and the work they
continue to do to make sure that we are
meeting the minimum standards for for
health requirements um we've taken
extraord ordinary steps to try to
mitigate all of those concerns uh
obviously any congregant setting there
is a risk of foodborn illness we're
fortunate that we have not had any
foodborn illnesses uh in our in the
Men's prison in conquered in fact in
none of our prison facilities um we're
taking extraordinary steps to reduce the
the rodent population that's impacting
the entire facility and uh and I'm very
proud of the work that they've done
because it it has been difficult and
it's been a difficult several months for
them to overcome those as far as
efficiencies go um we know we are
spending a lot of money on water a lot
of money on electricity a lot of money
on other resources that could definitely
be improved upon with a new facility as
far as exact numbers I don't have those
for you in front of uh in front of me
today but I can certainly ask our team
to try to uh drive up some estimations
on what our cost SA would be moving from
our current facility into a newer
facility okay a followup represent
Carrie go ahead so do you have any sense
of the opportunity costs for doing it
now as opposed to waiting another couple
years sure so we know that just in the
last year the cost of uh so since we put
this request in the cost of building a
new facility the estimation has gone up
almost
16% so uh nearly 16% inflation on cost
of building a new prison since we
originally put the 50 million request in
I can only imagine that it's going to
continue to Rise um as we as we wait or
as we try to come up with a solution I
think that our best opportunity is now
um if not only for the economic value
but also for the Safety and Security
value of both our residents and our
staff thank you uh yes representative
fauler please thank
you I almost hesitate to ask a question
because I'm anticipating the answer but
could you explain the state-of-the-art
of privately owned and operated prisons
and whether that has any possibility of
helping our problem
here so right now uh there is State
legislation that prohibits the state of
New Hampshire from entering into a
privately contracted prison uh operation
so we have not uh explored that as an
option all right yes for uh okay thank
you represent fuler further questions
please of assistant commissioner Raymond
from the committee any further questions
of the assistant commissioner okay I
think seeing none thank you very much
for coming in and do do making your
presentation and answering our questions
please assist thank you very much but we
will be in touch okay now I just I the
my next witness is Devin chasy chafy of
the ACLU of New Hampshire doesn't
indicate on your pink card the position
and I just want to for Miss chaffy and
the rest of the committee at 10:45 we an
Exe on Executive session on two bills so
I may have to to stop because some
people may want to see these bills exact
for a few minutes recess these this
hearing and go into an executive session
on the our two bills and then we'll come
right back so I think you've got two
minutes so make your pre and maybe a
question or two then I'm going to recess
this hearing close to 10:45 absolutely
representative and I I shouldn't be long
so thank you so much uh and thank you so
much to the committee for the
opportunity to testify before you today
my name is Devon chaffy I'm the
executive director of the ACLU uh
American civil liberties Union of New
Hampshire and we are not taking a
position on this bill uh before you
today and the reason why I'm here to
testify is because this is a shift from
our previous position where we had
actually opposed um this funding um and
so uh I wanted to clarify our position
on this funding today as the ACLU we
have generally been skeptical of paying
out taxpayer dollars towards um
incarceration uh and we have also been
very concerned with some of the
condition issues in the current men's
State Prison and getting those addressed
as quickly as possible as has already
been discussed um however we do very
much understand uh the very dire
situation currently at the men's State
Prison and the impact that that has both
on the folks that work there as well as
the and the folks that reside there um I
have been to the state prison uh
numerous times as a visitor and um in my
own personal personal estimation I think
anybody who enters that facility it it
it's very clear why you would need to
replace that facility and why the issues
with the facility cannot be corrected
through repairs personally I don't think
it's a close call um and I think that
the current conditions do have a severe
impact both on the folks that work there
as well as on the um on the residents uh
you know I think it was uh Senator gray
actually put it uh well when he talked
about the need to continue to reduce
recidivism um and the impact that having
proper facilities can have and
ultimately reducing recidivism and
therefore reducing the C cost of
incarcerations to the state I would just
clearly state that as we move forward H
and if this body decides to move forward
with the money to replace the Men's
prison I would urge continued
legislative oversight of three things
first first and ensuring that there is
adequate health facilities in these um
in the new U Men's prison that is
critical um and quite frankly will save
the state a lot in the long run as far
as any potential lawsuits of having
inadequate Health Care Facilities as
well as to preserving the health of
those who are there uh education
facilities uh are are also the second
thing that I would um urge the legis uh
legis uh legislative body to focus on is
representative Eaton highlighted um the
various skill building as well as
educational opportunities are key to
continuing to reduce recidivism and
reintegrate individual residents into
our communities and finally making sure
that whatever space is built in this
facility is uh is does not increase the
number of beds and in fact keeps Pace
with the continuing decrease and what we
have seen in the population um we heard
in answer to representative uh fidal
questions that in fact we have uh 200 uh
beds that are currently not being
utilized or approximately thereof at the
state prison and so if uh we are going
to continue to see this reduction in
incarceration at our state prisons the
state taxpayers should not be paying uh
for beds that we are not using um and so
uh with these three factors in mind uh
healthc care education and right sizing
the facility um I think those are all
three things that are critical for you
all to keep in mind as you oversee this
facility should you decide to approve
this moving forward thank you so much
okay uh I'm looking at the committee
clock and it is close to 10:45 so what
I'm going to do to make it easier for
the Comm if you don't mind staying
probably take just 10 to 15 minutes to
exec these next two bills and if you
could come back and answer any questions
committee me is that okay yeah because I
have people who may want to for the and
it's been absolutely of course 10:45 of
course thank you all right thank you
very much Miss CH I'm going to now
recess the public hearing on Senate Bill
476 and I'm now going to open the
executive session on uh Senate bills 580
and
592 I thought wanted you to wait till oh
Mark okay I'm sorry Mark back okay all
right so wanted to be here session all
right so that's probably it we just in a
recess recess um okay why don't we take
a a 10minute recess I'm sorry about that
and I appreciate people's cooperation
but the chair would like to be here and
when we scheduled we didn't realize we'd
have this bill too so we had to scramble
and I'm Sor yeah got 10 minutes don't
you we bring her back okay all right so
unless there's any objection we'll bring
Miss chaffy back then sorry about that
all right thank you very much for your
help guys uh continue please I wasn't
aware of some of this information for
question oh yeah open for questions to
miss chaffy please
questions on Miss okay yes go ahead
represent car so why didn't you take a
position on this previously and why now
so previously we had opposed the funding
and I think we were concerned about the
the use of taxpayers money going towards
incarceration I think we had some
concerns that there might be an attempt
to expand the facility as there often
are um and I think we have sense um
especially and quite frankly in
listening to the department and the
Department's argument and me me
personally thinking through my
experience and having visited the
facility have come to the opinion that
repairs are not sufficient and that
there needs to be a replacement facility
and so where our Focus as an
organization should be now is on making
sure that this is done correctly okay
all right thank you uh further questions
of Miss chaffy for members of the
committee there any further questions
see n thank you very much for coming
your understanding with our situation
thank you very much oh you're welcome CL
okay should I don't if there anybody
else wants to testify for or against
this bill and seeing on the only other
thing is the blue sheets we probably
need to read those if we're going to if
nobody else wants to testify and then
we'll move right into the executive
session the chair is here
now I appreciate everybody's Indulgence
especially those who are waiting for the
next two bills to be
EXA
all right thank you um thank you we we
will close the first
hearing I would like to open executive
session on Senate Bill 592 renaming
Route 127 from Central Street in
Franklin the Town Line in samton is
Officer Bradley hos Memorial
Highway um
be uh we typically uh were in executive
session decide this uh it's atypical to
take testimony but in in light of uh of
this subject I'm happy to recognize
Captain Brendan is it Davey
sir could you please come
forward welcome to public
works good morning ladies and gentlemen
I appreciate your taking my testimony
which I hope will be mercifully brief um
I I would submit uh that the department
of safety is strongly in support of this
piece of legislation the only
recommendation I I might humbly suggest
is that because uh in his Decades of
service the rank of Chief was that to
which uh Mr hos ascended uh At His
Highest I might suggest that uh his his
naming on this on this highway be the
chief Bradley T House Highway um and I
thank you all very much for your time
and
consideration thank you sir for your
service and coming here and and offering
that suggestion are there any questions
seeing none thank you sir thank
you for the uh is there anyone else
wishing to speak for or against atypical
I will mention one more time very
appreciated of having you coming before
us
today the um we have a we do
please please introduce yourself yes
good morning my name is Lee barones I'm
a state traffic engineer with New
Hampshire do I'm not for or against I'm
here simply if there are any questions
uh by the committee uh with regarding to
posting the sign that's usually the uh
responsibility of of the bureau that I
work with certain so just making my
presence known thank you sir thank you
um seeing no no further testimony we
have uh the only thing that was holding
us back from an executive for um going
into this was a letter specifically from
the town of Franklin you have one signed
by the mayor here uh with their letter
of support for Senate Bill
592 um I I very much appreciative of the
suggestion that was made to add Chief
instead of
Officer I think that's I think that's a
wonderful tribute yes please
representative uh if I could ask I am
the immediate past president of the
Franklin Business and Professional
Women's Association and I do have a
statement from them if you would allow
me I I would be happy to permit you that
please okay
um we're reaching out to inform you of
our enthusiastic support for Route 127
being dedicated to former Chief Franklin
chief of police Bradley hos who was
tragically taken away from us way too
soon former Chief hos served Franklin
for decades
always keeping the safety of the
community first and foremost his
dedication was an inspiration to his
fellow police officers and he is sorely
missed the designation is a wonderful
tribute to him thank
you yes
please question of the chair do we need
an an amendment to to do this or is the
wording the sign really up to the
department I I I would believe the
cleanest as just so there's no I I it
would need to be an amendment I would I
would welcome an
amendment um we've delayed this process
so I'm wondering if we
could okay thank you yes uh gentleman
from the
do yes so so the the question is we have
it we have it listed as officer Bradley
I believe many of us would be in favor
of Chief
Bradley
um how's the process go forward if that
change was are are because of the
legislative intent would they would they
be locked to that or should we
U we we usually work with the sponsors
on the actual design of the sign um
however it is usually best that the
uh text of the sign be part of the
legislation or at least somehow made
clear that that was the legislative
intent um so that going back through
history we have the record uh of the leg
legislation I'm just saying that um I I
look back at some of the signs that have
been put up decades ago that we have to
restore or replace and we go back to the
uh the legislation for that information
and so if there's a discrepancy
that may not be easily discovered so if
it's possible an amendment or some sort
of notation um that's in the record
would would assist us but it is not it's
not the
end thank you for
that I know that
um I know that several of the members
here have commitments for other
activities they have to be at today I uh
extremely appreciative the fact that
everyone has adjusted their schedule so
we could have a near maximum vote on
this because I know how we all feel
about this if um if I were to speak to
lob to pull an amendment with that
simple change would the uh committee be
willing to wait till uh 12:30 to uh to
exec this out repr
it's a single word for moving officer
and placing the chief and I would think
with the public acknowledgement here in
the faith in our chairman that we could
vote now with the understanding it's a
one-word amendment that the chairman
will take care of
okay discussion on that
point yes please
sir thank you sir um I would submit to
the committee that I will be meeting
with the hos family and the governor
this afternoon at State Police
Headquarters uh for his
recognition um of the hos family and
other members of New Hampshire hospital
who were there on November 17th would it
potentially satisfy the the committee
that um the highway would be named in
his honor in a manner consistent with
the wishes of the hos family in terms of
title that way whatever it is that they
would say whether it's Chief or officer
I suspect they're going to appreciate
Chief would be something that you could
vote upon now and uh provided that I
could um uh guarantee to you by virtue
of my face-to-face conversation with the
hos family today what it is that they'd
like okay thank you sir yes sir so we we
are uh yes I'm sorry represent faul I
mean I was I I think I like the idea of
the amendment but I think we can express
the intent of the committee and either
finalize it at 12:30 or finalize it on
Thursday
uh we we can announce now an executive
session for the lunch break on Thursday
or something I I I think we can we can
express the intent of the committee at
any rate I as as much as I Look to You
for counsel all the time the um
I I from what that conversation and the
delay unfortunately of where we have and
not having the mayor's letter I think
it's important that we vote this through
right now so that um these gentlemen and
and the governor have the opportunity to
say that it's been passed and we will um
like we can always go to the Senate and
have the change made I don't don't see
that that's going to be an issue we can
we can we can make we we could make when
the motion's made we could make the
motion that officer
Chief um and um
I just we we need we need to resolve
this at this point in time yes the
chairman as a longtime member of this
committee we've done things like this
before so and there wasn't a lot of
controversy so I say I'm just pass an
amendment with the understanding that
you'd take work on changing it from
change it from officer to Chief and we
vote the bill off to pass today so we
can get to the floor by next week uh so
I would say go ahead I further further
discussion of the uh committee yes
please go ahead represent Boer I um also
support that idea of doing that I think
it's the most expedient way we could
deal with the situation as it is only a
one-word change Amendment and I think we
do have our faith in you that it would
be followed through
appropriately thank you
okay Gra Jack uh thank you this is not
exactly regular order but there is the
possibility of doing it with a floor
amendment when the bill comes to the
floor I know there are often technical
Corrections that are made that
way as as much as I would like to agree
with you my when we come to the floor
with this which won't be this week it'd
be the following week from my
conversations with the clerk and the
fam's the family's going to be in the
gallery I i' I'd rather not be doing
that uh so we could um someone could
offer um and we pass it with the upgrade
of the title and then if I need to make
a correction on the floor we can do that
repent Mr chairman I would move that the
committee authorize the chair to change
the word officer to the word Chief and
the motion be ought to pass with
Amendment
okay so motion by Eaton I don't know who
the second was yeah represent melv
represent Melvin was a
second discussion on
that
okay
um when you have a chance uh we will
call the role if you're in favor of the
motion or of ought to pass with
Amendment
uh signify by saying I if you're opposed
nay um with that is there any further
discussion okay so one question we're
voting on that that would be the
question I just asked thank you
okay
yes the amend changing that one word I I
think so and then then then that'll be
easier I think than than saying this was
passed with an Amendment we're going to
so my understanding is that we would
the chief change officer Chief
okay I think that's cleaner and I'll
I'll I'll draft Amendment if need
be
okay
please we're all set
yes in that case representative cludia
uh yes representative Mills
yes representative
fideli representative
Newton is absent abent sorry
representative
kazinski representative Bowden yes
representative Boyd is absent
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative
Connor representative Jack
yes representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar
I representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman
yes representative Eaton
yes representative Peterson
yes representative Kerry yes
representative jurus
yes chairman mccon chairman votes I
Mr chair the motion passes
180 thank you for that um good ask the
committee one more time to stand for a
moment of
silence thank
you
Mr chairman yes does that cover both the
amendment that vote cover both the
amendment
and the bill itself yes yes thank
you it's a little different procedure
but we will we will make it work however
that does thank you uh we have another
executive session
scheduled uh which is uh
um what's on the second
second 580 I would like to I would like
to adjourn I would like to recess that
hearing um until 11:30 I have another
I'm hoping is still delayed when I go
down there and we'll take this up at
11:30 and then be be done our business
before lunch okay thank
you
e
I'm sorry to brush you back in here the
um is there anyone wishing to uh
speak on our next executive session
which is Senate Bill
580 think you
a do you have a did we have a pink card
from you
sir yep please do we just we have a
couple moments still
left orang take care
of turn turn the mic on yep I'm John
Evans with the New Hampshire Department
of Transportation um I'm the noise
program manager I was just uh letting
you know that I was here and available
for questions if there
are and the uh department is taking no
position or taking a position uh at this
time I believe no position okay thank
you
you don't you don't need to fill that
out
sir before I open the hearing is the
department received a stockpile of cash
that we didn't know about since we last
met okay
what a good $2 investment every week
huh time uh time being uh
11:30 I would like to uh open the um exe
executive session on 580 FN authorizing
the sale of toll credits to fund a newly
established noise barrier construction
fund for the design and construction of
noise barrier
projects is there anyone on the
committee uh cares to make a
motion seeing none
um I will offer
um itl expedient um on Senate Bill 580
FN out second okay never mind represent
F
second representative fidelia I believe
is offered a
second uh before I take
discussion um for many years I have sat
here and heard the heartfelt concerns of
residents that live alongside our
highway
system and um wish there was a way that
we could um we could
expend millions of dollars for that
purpose but
unfortunately the um federal guidelines
which permit a certain uh certain roads
under certain conditions with um spacing
between buildings and neighborhoods and
everything else comp Le Lex uh many
times many many times I believe the
department had a list of two or three
pages um that those projects uh do not
um do not meet that criteria which then
would would come from either general
fund or uh Highway expenses and as we
just came through the 10-year
plan especially with the turnpike uh
there's presently already leakage on um
on some of of our former
projects uh there's not been a
willingness to raise tolls for a great
number of years and
um so that the process isn't there the
the revenue is not there and we would I
believe as policy makers uh be an error
toh suggest to anyone that there is the
use of toll credits uh we have come to
find out from
testimony um has not been rising at any
any great degree and the need for those
toll credits for other projects um have
been ever becoming um ever increasingly
uh uh important uses to uh back up the
monies that we need for federal
programs the the method and the senator
and others
um I do not fault for bringing this
forward but the method of
funding uh this uh noise barrier
additions is taking our toll credits and
putting them out on the open market and
exchanging what other states might pay
for those credits to make this
fund and most times in in my life
experiences uh you you wouldn't see
states that are strapped for as much
money as we are uh offering a surplus
for those so as much as I think this is
a creative solution it's not the right
solution at this point and for those
reasons I offered U my motion further
discussion represent Jack uh thank you
Mr chairman one other item is if I
understood the testimony correctly
despite the fact it's been authorized
for several years the marketplace has
never been actually set up so in that
sense the bill is premature and could be
brought forward if one actually is set
up thank you yes represent
fogner um I want to agree with the
Chairman's remarks entirely I just want
to emphasize that I think that we have
shied away from earmarks and for you
know in advance setting
aside um money from Individual projects
and types of projects so that uh I I
think this is an example if this were
new money coming from someplace that it
might
be different but I don't think we've
heard that there's any increase in in
Revenue that's coming with this so I
would would agree with the Ito thank you
sir any further discussion represent uh
yes as a longtime member of this
committee I'm I'm sympathetic to the
people who want noise bears and I
believe we we put something in the
tenure plan using federal funds to
construct a noise bear around I95 in
Portsmouth so and that and that was the
first one just for everybody's
edification I first learned about this
issue in 1999 when I was on the
committee
and the one of the members from
Portsmouth was a real she was a real
Advocate and she pushed for years and
she couldn't get it through you know but
eventually I think we put in in the last
10-year plan and I believe it's in
Portsmith only I mean it's a start it's
I I feel sad we can't do more but I
think right now the turnpike system
really needs more Revenue I don't know
what we do and I think we got to be
careful with our toll credits thank
you thank you uh further further comment
on this on this yes thank
you yes please chairman um just as a
comment the more we widen the turnpike
the more we widen these roads the more
emphasis upfront in the project that
should be put on uh the the sound
barriers uh we're starting to encroach
on residential areas uh maybe uh schools
Etc what along the right away um I see
the project I see the widening on um the
Everett it looks like they're putting up
a wall on on northbound side as part of
the
project I you like you mentioned you've
been you've seen this uh over and over
again and at some point we're gonna I I
would believe that the do via funding
from from the legislator is going to
have to back on
something to mitigate noise I appreciate
the representative's comments any
further questions or uh discussion prior
to calling the
role seeing none the motion is itl if
you are in favor of that motion you'll
signify by saying I or yes and if you
oppose nay or no with that the clerk
will call the role thank you Mr
chair representative cluder yes
representative Mills votes yes repes
representative
fidi representative Newton is excused
kazinski representative
Bowden representative Boyd is excuse
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative Connor yes
representative Jack yes representative
Abbott yes representative Edgar I
representative
Faulkner representative Newman yes
representative Eaton yes representative
Peterson yes representative kery yes
representative jurus yes chairman mcon
chairman votes I Mr chair the motion
passes
180 thank you I would um I would like to
go back U we are in recess um from
Senate Bill 592 we have an amendment
before us
I'm sorry are we gonna be consent is
there any objection to
consent uh it'll be on consent thank you
thank you both I don't believe there was
a blue sheet that was uh no blue sheet
okay okay we uh we have I'm going to go
back to Senate Bill 592
uh we have uh represent Eaton was kind
enough to run across the street and uh
provide an amendment the amendment is uh
1452 which should be for you uh amending
the title of the bill to be replaced
with the following renaming Route 127
from Central Street to Franklin Town
Line of samton as Chief Bradley hos
Memorial Highway it was a change from
Chief to officer I believe the um state
that we're here was yes is uh is more
appropriate um so we have the amendment
before us if you're in favor of the uh
of the accepting the amendment
1452 would you signify by raising your
hand shows
unanimous can I one further
Amendment okay the solity of
the bill and importance of the bill in
the long time history of the bill I
would move that we amend the maker of
the motion to be the chair of the
committee instead of
representa so that chair is
the shows the
importance of the
committee thank you um I don't
uh represent Ms although I appreciate
that motion and I totally half agree
with it I don't see how I well I I I
agree with the good half I I don't I
don't see how delaying this process at
that time to change it from Eaton to
makoni do thetion
overall to pass with amend
thee it's the chair oh okay it's up to
the chair as far as I'm concerned so we
can change it from your your name to
don't worry about the
amendment Amendment on on the committee
committee
report okay yep I I agree with that uh
represent
parison
yeah
wait thank you representative I I
believe uh gentleman left us a phone
number we're going to check the record
or we'll call the commissioner Quinn and
make sure the governor's office that
they're aware of this great suggestion
yes r
f
yes and I did have a conversation with
the clerk um saying that we're meeting
today was it something that you know I
should notify the sponsor and the family
of and he said we it would be best to
wait till the next session and that date
wasn't certain at that
time all right is everyone clear on what
the motion
is okay if you're if you're in favor of
amendment
1452 uh renaming rout 127 Central
Franklin and it will the name Will
reside as Chief Bradley Hof Memorial
Highway uh would you signify by saying I
or yes and if you opposed to the motion
nay or no and with that the clerk will
call the
role caught the clerk with his pants now
did you
not representative cluder
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative fideli yes representative
Newton is excused representative
kazinski representative
Bowden representative Boyd is excused
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative Connor yes
representative Jack yes representative
Abbott yes representative Edgar I
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton yes representative Peterson yes
representative Carrie yes representative
J
yes chairman makoni chairman votes I 180
the motion passes chairman thank
you we have uh we have no more business
before us today before I before I turn
to the vice chairman okay the
um the suggestion this morning for a uh
State Prison tour I think is a is
especially Timely
and we will work with the commissioner
to do that represent Graham Comm
chairman not
to will
individ I
personally Ur
anybody
thank
you I U I have some concerns of sending
individuals over maybe they'll end up
staying so I yeah so I in all honesty
you're going to need to prepare yourself
if you've never been there before it's a
different uh it's not the women's prison
tour that we when many of us went on
previously so we will we will arrange
that that's a wonderful uh suggestion
that um that if there are people that
can't join us they typically will meet
over here we'll go over by a van and
they'll return us back here so unlike
the uh college system we don't usually
have lunch over there and from what we
what we've heard of their uh facility we
will decline that offer so um we have
um I believe we have
um I know if we've disposed of our last
Senate Bill I know there was we this was
the last one we had today today we still
have today's yeah today
he so what's the pleasure was if I don't
know if we're going to be in session
next week um would you like to see if
we're a lighter schedule that maybe we
convene after or during lunch of that to
take care of that business or would you
like to come in as a separate day I'm
open m Mr chair just that for
everybody's clarify when is the date
that we have have to have this bill out
I understand this is an early Bill
something about going to finance and I
don't know whether this is
necessary this now has an FN back on it
it well it yeah I think it has and there
some concerns uh that myself and some of
the other members that it might have to
go to a second which I assume would be F
I'm sure it does uh but I believe on
this okay all right let me let me speak
to the clerk and see what see what needs
to be done rep uh thank you Mr chairman
uh on the bill uh
476 the question I have is I guess would
be to the treasur is if this would
affect the amount we would be able to
bond in the capital budget next year I
think that's a critical question for
this I I I believe that's a great
question so I don't I will ask our our
researcher to reach out to uh the
treasurer than excuse me Mr I'm sorry
yes please go right uh okay a request
maybe we could ask the treasurer to come
in and talk to us about this bill uh
because there some concerns Among Us
that how it's going to impact not only
this year but the next capital budget
it's a big amount of money so I've said
suggestions we get the treasure and
maybe even bring in the Attorney General
to talk about is there a real need like
maybe there maybe know something about
an impending lawsuit I don't know but I
had questions and concern from some
members of the committee they would like
to see those two people come to a work
session and maybe then we can exec the
bill and I I appreciate former
representative Grahams AR arranging a
tour and probably we need to do that
above all before we
exec okay thank you I will um I will
speak to the clerk I will speak to uh
Finance chair and see where we need to
be and if we need to act quicker then we
can get then we can bring those Council
before us and we're going to ask for
written testimony from them so why don't
you forward the questions to myself I
will speak with chrisy and as soon as I
know maybe today I'll I hope to know
tomorrow I'll know tomorrow on the floor
today is Wednesday yeah today
tomorrow and um so we should be able to
communicate tomorrow what what we're
going to need to do but if let's if we
were to go back
to it would appear that we are going to
have to meet sooner than
later um next week is is there if
because I'd have to make the calendar
today and if we
can't let me just look at what my
schedule
is
would uh next Thursday the 18th or the
19th work for the
committee do we have session on the 18th
well if we had the 18th would you be
opposed during the lunch hour if uh the
Freshman legislators of this committee
were to pay for uh Pizza that we come
here for lunchtime
and I have no no problem with the pizza
but is is would that lunch hour give us
enough time to thoroughly so we talked
about the treasure let's let's let's
look at the 19th then yeah well the 19th
is a Friday the the Democrats we have a
retreat that day so just for your
information so I like not you know we
won't be able to make that Friday then
I'm sorry but that's schu a retreat a
dayong retreat yeah it's a day long
retreat and it's going to be in out of
it's not going to be here it's going to
be in Manchester
okay 20 the 20 3rd May 3rd is going to
be uh schools out for the
week so a lot of folks are going to be
on
vacation
from2 okay let me go back to my
calendar but if that's spring break we
can come in here and get wild and gra
yeah right not again we we can't can't
we can't times have change the
um the 17th next
Wednesday is that it's fine with me I
don't know about the
rest we
um 10
o'clock anyone like 11 o'clock better
you want to get your day done I can't go
9 o'clock so let's go 10 o'
10 o'clock on the 17th is that what we
just said yeah I think y okay so we'll
just go ahead and schedule
it so this sort of like a work executive
session possibly Mr chair I don't know
how we put it how we will put it if
there any estimate on I do have a
commitment that I can change it that's
easier to change for me that a an
afternoon commitment in Nash will
curious if we push lunch back a little
we'll be out of here by one I suspect
we'll be out of here by 12 12:30 okay
it's really just it's really just SM of
hearing the questions hearing from the
treasurer hearing from Finance what
their pleasure is I can I know they
don't want to bring in any bills this
you know this round but maybe the maybe
the need Rises to that I don't know
thank you Mr chair okay Mr chair would
we be looking at the tour before then or
I I don't know I don't know that answer
okay
I think I think we we can we can make an
arrangement uh yeah that's a good point
um why don't
um yeah let's start with that how how
many reps haven't been there that would
like to
go so we
have from what I've heard just for me
personally I don't necessarily need to
go but if if it's convenient I I I'll
join in uh just from pictures the
testimony what we heard last year um
there's
a why don't what's feeling of we we
schedule and see if it could work uh 11
o'clock 10:30 going over there and doing
our work at 1
o'clock that same day the 17th works for
me Wednesday the 17th that would be
maybe a tour and then a work s y so
immediate immediately following when we
come back work session slash U is it is
that
agreeable
yes downstairs we'll be why don't we
meet downstairs at the in the lobby of
this building for 10 o'clock and
typically they'll roll
in we we'll send you some in stagram
pictures
represent okay thank you for that show
you where you're
bunking well we're not to that point yet
so hold hold hold your
vote okay all right so um any any other
business before
us seeing none I sincerely appreciate
everyone with their efforts to be here
today okay thank you
Mr
e